les fondations privées ont un actif de
mille milliards de dollars en amérique
du nord ces fondations au canada doivent
donner 3 5 % de leurs actifs
annuellement à différentes causes
doivent dépenser 3 5% ottawa a lancé des
consultations publiques pour vérifier la
possibilité d'augmenter cette obligation
charitable avec nous ce soir brigitte
alepin professeur en fiscalité à
l'université du québec en outaouais
bonsoir
ans marc quel est le régime fiscal
brigitte alepin des fondations privées
de charité
c'est un régime fiscal qui est en trois
volets si on veut dans un premier temps
on a fait un crédit d'impôt aux
fondateurs un crédit d'impôt qui varient
d'une province à l'autre qui peut
atteindre 50 4 % dépendamment de la
province ici au québec c'est environ 55
en proposant dépendamment des situations
et donc d'une part un bon cadeau d'impôt
pour le fondateur moment où est ce qu'il
créé sa fondation la fondation lehmann
est totalement exemple donc un congé
fiscal total à perpétuité et en
contrepartie de 10 ans on souhaite que
les fondations redonne à la société donc
leurs obligations charitable et de 3.5
pour ça lycée ou canada on les oblige à
dépenser à chaque année 3 points 5 % de
la valeur de leur capital donc un actif
de 100 millions faut dépenser 3 millions
500 mille
exactement et c'est un petit peu
c'est un petit peu plus
nuancé qu'elle soit dans un certain sens
parce qu'il
considère dans ce 3 millions 500 mille
les dépenses d'exploitation ou
d'administration de la fondation dont
wei ce que la fondation dépenses à
chaque année pour mon père et on
considère ça comme la charité dont
puisqu'une fondation dépense environ
points 104 points 75 % sont quatre à
chaque année en moyenne à de la charte
et on pense que ce qui semble à arles
dépenses d'administration c'est à dire
on pense que ce qui sans avoir
réellement la charité c'est environ 2
sans son capitaine alors quand on parle
de fondations privées on en a quelques
exemples qui existe dans notre société
la fondation chagnon par exemple la
fondation de marcelle et jean coutu la
fondation chagnon ces deux milliards
cent cinquante millions de dollars au
dernier exercice financier d'actifs la
fondation rossi la fondation de marcelle
et jean coutu la fondation également de
mirella et lino saputo ce sont de
grosses fondation elles ont donc cette
obligation du 3 5% mais là il ya des
consultations au canada pour aller à
quoi 4 5%
dans les derniers dans certaines
discussions qui parle de 7 % par exemple
des conservateurs proposent 7.5 pour ça
donc si on souhaite que la fondation
redonne à la commande à redonner à la
société
un excédent de du cadeau d'un coup qu'on
a donnée aux fondateurs donc son souhait
qu'elle commence à être payant pour la
société dans un délai de vingt ans de sa
création faudrait augmenter le taux
environ 6% et ça c'est si on considère
que les dépenses d'administration font
plus partie du quelques mais là si on
augmente ce taux là est ce qu'on va pas
tuer la poule aux oeufs d'or et
éventuellement parce que on va entamer
le capital l'objectif des fondations
c'est de garder du capital pour être
capable de faire du rendement et de
donner de l'argent mais si on vient
gruger dans le capital un moment donné
il a repris la fondation
et
c'est un 17 personnes qui disent que
c'est ça l'objectif de la fondation
d'autres personnes il ya d'autres très
grands risques qui pensent autre chose
mais une chose qui est certaine qu'elle
que soit notre vision des fondations il
faut que ce soit un des quarante ans
pour les contribuables donc si on met en
place ce système qui permet aux
fondateurs un économie d'impôt de 53% au
départ de son de son capital et à chaque
année la fondation paient pas d'impôts
sur ses revenus d'investissements il
faut qu'un mandat suffisamment en en
redonne suffisamment la société pour
couvrir le coût de ces cadeaux pour la
est présentement à 3.5 pour ça on ne
trouve pas du couvent en fait aux
français qu'en temps avant qu'on
commence à rentrer dans le tard jean
mouly contribuer à avancer quelqu'un la
valeur des cadeaux qu'on donne aux
fondateurs de la fondation excède ce que
la fondation redonne à la société est ce
que dans votre calcul jeter le thème
vous vous vous prenez en compte le fait
que les fondations viennent peut-être
c'est un choix de société la soulager
certaines charges du gouvernement de par
leur présence philanthropique dans
certains secteurs en éducation en santé
ou en culture
oui c'est sûr qu'il ya des avantages
comme par exemple on c'est important
d'avoir de la philanthropie parce que
certaines activités que le gouvernement
ne peut pas faire fait conspuer soul est
fine entre plus pour les femmes mais il
faut que ça soit rancart pour les
finances publiques il faut que le cadeau
pour des noms fondateur et le cadeau
qu'on donne aux fondations soient
rentables pour les finances publiques
c'est c'est
mathématique donc ils font refaire les
calculs et c'est pour ça que le
gouvernement fédéral lance ses
consultations et vous c'est quoi votre
chiffre si c'est pas 3,5 vous proposez
quoi
mais si on souhaite vous savez quand on
fait un investissement par exemple dans
un business il ya certaines sources de
business qu'on dit on veut que ce soit à
rentrer à l'intérieur d'une période de
dix ans un immeuble donc
dépendamment du site et d'investissement
on a un nombre critères de rentabilité
sont souhaite que les fondations comment
c'est quelque chose qui est avantageux
pour la société dans une période de 20
ans 6 et 20 ans de fourchette c'est
mathématique il faut augmenter le compte
de l'obligation paritaire des fondations
à minimum 5 points 5 à 6 % sont souhaite
que les fondations par exemple aux idées
on pense qu'une fondation ça devrait pas
durer plus que 50 ans baston moment le
faut les augmenter davantage mais c'est
un choix de société à l'intérieur de
complétant on souhaite que ses
fondations là commence est rentable pour
notre se situe présentement ses 50 ans
le délai parfait merci merci pour cette
perspective ce soit à brigitte à terre
merci beaucoup pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
r d